yes we did cuz we back at it again it's
the fighter in the kid this is really
the fighter in the kid come on baby how
excited are you dude well I'm trying not
when a large black man comes in this
building I go oh Brian's going to be Rob
it's also Adrien Peterson so I'm trying
to there's there's this there's this um
phenomenon that straight men have like
me where they have a tendency to get an
erection gay out we gay out okay I'm
surprised you didn't bring your wife
dude you guys are just all into black
guys
that's not that's not public information
we' talked about it no I understand but
my wife my wife I would never do that to
her because um she's Adrien Peterson
yeah I think but he's everybody's type
including a straight man like me I mean
it's fair to say with the Symmetry and
and the whole thing going on and and he
can dance well when I see him when I see
him I get PTSD and I'll bring it up to
him but last time I saw that man he rush
for about 200 yards and beat us 50 to 3
I haven't seen him since I was that was
in
2005 or 2006 did you know we haven't
seen each other but when I see him dude
it's on
site I'm going to say hey dude do you
remember when you beat the brakes off of
us cuz I do bro and now what's up Daddy
I'm hoping he's a little out of shape
you've been dancing dance this no I have
a much better idea challenge him to a
foot race and tear both your hamstrings
again I would not challenge him to a
foot
that guy can run yeah I would imagine
he's a little F I've SE him run with
pads on I can only imagine naked yeah
yeah he could drag a car behind him and
be faster than me I think yeah yeah it's
a different thing we had a lot to talk
about I feel like you and I haven't seen
each other in a hot second well I'd like
to talk for a second about the fact that
you you souped your truck up to the
degree don't say soup though whatever it
is whatever are saying soup okay you
tricked it out this isn't Fast and
Furious don't say soup well your truck
could be in Fast and Furious because
frankly it's the cars on there yeah it
sounds like I sent I sent Brian a video
of the exhaust and send the video and
underneath put not. for. you yeah yeah
it sounds like you know when in the
movie where they go they just hear the
ground start to shake and they all
go it's coming are you talking about
Jurassic Park you talking about Jurassic
Park where the water's going yeah yeah
yeah that's what it is and that's what
your car feels like Overkill 1,000 is
that the company that's company Overkill
well 1,000 represents the horsepower
so your truck is a th horsepower is that
legal how is that legal it's not but the
thing is is even a thousand being
generous cuz actually 1050 I hope a
bunch of environmental activists glue
their hands to your truck I will piss on
them well you'll just you'll take them
for a drag yeah no I'll just pee on them
yeah but that they'll be like whatever
and then I
just it's it's insane it's so much fun
though cuz Jay met us up in Sacramento
so me and tiger flew up there and then
we spent all day at the shop then we
drove back it's about 6 hour drive back
and you just spent all day at the shop
just watching him TW it up uh that
talking about and then we're we're
coming out with a new uh show for it all
around automotives so if there was a
bodybuilder as a car that's what your
car is that's what your car looks like
that's the Adrian Peterson of TRS it's
big and it's fast yeah damn Gooding I
feel like it's
the I don't know is it the adri in
Peterson or is it it just it feels like
the rock of this scared me got a lot so
I was like oh my God then I take off oh
my God it's a 10sec try is that fire
coming out of the back yeah is it Fire
coming out Brandon a 10c truck Brandon
Brandon what
no it's your everyday driver you can't
have a race car but I had to go out I
know it's not going to stop there cuz
there's only one way to go up from here
there is you be bigger blower on there
biger super I can get to 13400 each you
don't need a bigger blower why not have
the baddest Dino in all the land there's
a there's a whole subculture of people
that are this [__] oh yeah it doesn't
stop there because because the
connection I made through like kib Tech
with Ryan and Josh at Overkill and the
boys at toyot tires and add all that I'm
like dude how dope would it be to do
this to other people's cars yeah so then
I'm going start I'm going to do a show
where I give back and build people's
dream cars and then some my dream cars
as a kid like the lightning since I was
a kid that was like the Northstar Ford
Lightning could never afford it I'm
gonna get a lightning redo that turn
into a current lightning with over a
thousand horsepower we do typhoon
Cyclones dope people like people that
you would do this for are they all 14
years old or are they're adults like oh
no they're not cucks so that's why
you're not going to be interested in it
yeah they're not cucks that just go I'll
take a Tesla wait oh check this out big
black guy come to my house no listen no
it's for people that are actually not CS
you can't call me a C I'm not you are
though but it's not for you that's why
when I send you that stuff I put not for
for you I mean that I got that text I
got just the back of his truck and I
said not for you not das4 Dash you and
I'm like and I said Brendon please leave
it there you could be the opposite of
the fan base I'm going for yeah but no
cucks apply can you please not so it's a
no [__] zone no [__] Zone like no
nobody's going to watch my shows like I
can't decide do I want to do this or get
a Tesla that's not how I talk dude it is
though anyone that drives Tesla talks
like this don't talk don't turn me into
a [__] just because anyone bu Tesla can
dance and also suck [__] right no the
rules just because I'm into beautiful
black men doesn't mean that dick and
huge [__] doesn't mean that I'm gay no
no mean you like Teslas no it means you
like Teslas we know how this goes dude
oh my God but yeah it was fun man I
can't wait never been more excited about
something I guess so man let me let me
let me suit my body up with my magic M
see if this gets me into th D if I take
this I'm going to challenge Adrien
Pearson to a foot race is that right
yeah I'll be in my car and he'll be in
that but I won't let you I won't let you
no I don't want I can't blow out my
hammies even just yesterday I had to
coach up these little bastards playing
baseball yesterday and just had to run
Sprint for a ball I was like Daddy's
hammies are tight oh yeah you get tight
up oh man man I need to warm up for
these little I have taken to stretching
now I I do my I do my morning and even
more stuff dude oh hey hey that's please
I wake up I drink my green juice and
then I stretch I jump on my Tesla I
don't even have to think about no I did
De dips to failure yesterday yeah yeah C
stuff I did dip to failure yeah I did
deadlifts deadlifts and a thousand house
Poor House horsepower truck that's the
difference between it okay I did De
deadlifts or I did dips with no weight
you know that's silly I did dead I did
dips no weight I drink my green juice
and I just jump in my Tesla and I just
love that I can just get in it and just
go I don't have to worry about gas or
nothing like that I do I just show up I
just show up and then here I am no no I
show up and then but don't say that
that's I'm I'm I'm a man I'm a man I
couldn't be further from it Bud your car
is a little too big it's very tall it's
not for you yeah it's just not I don't
know why you the opposite demo I don't
know why you have sand colored I'm
surprised it's not
black it's C stuff right why is but your
color why don't they go with all black
well your color is a little bit like it
seems mushroom brown right no it's cam
it's Army tan that's the color that's
that's the definition of the color it's
called sand blast tan I guess it is sand
know I don't do black be why cuz every
[__] would pick black okay man you can't
choose my color this is why we can't
talk cards cuz T do you have all white I
just want white I don't even do you have
all black I just want black I try to go
as gay as I can with my car I try to go
literally I do have the cuck version of
a car it is a three it's an iPad with
wheels yeah you got to go unique colors
there you're going to see trxs that are
black red blue you don't see many sand
blast cuz there's only a thousand have
you always been in the truck so you were
always in the race car no I like
everything I've had Raptors before my
first car was a F-150 I always like
trucks when I met you you had the the
m6 MW BMW y but that's like for you now
you're like yeah you just grow up you
know now now um yeah all right well you
got now I had to I left Sacramento at
4:00 a.m. because I had to rush back to
make the Misfits pay-per-view which was
Logan Paul Dyan danis Tommy Fury KSI and
when I talk by the way you called that
Fight 2 a my question when I saw it I
went did he have some inside info no
that's so stupid I hate that narrative
when people like oh he got the script or
this is all fake I no no no I mean I
just mean did you talk to somebody who
was close to Dylan who said something
like I'm gonna [__] tackle him if go
no who would say hey Dyan get beat up on
the feet and he's going to do some
Antics he would take the fight that was
very that was crazy I I've had way
better calls than that this one to me is
not like I didn't know it was a thing
till Jay and George text me they're like
dude your predictions all over the place
I'm like the silly prediction that's
gonna be a DQ like it's everywhere like
what like I've had better predictions
than that I don't know I mean that's
he exactly 10 punches they say yeah he's
not a boxer and even if you look at his
MMA fights like his striking was it was
not good and then now you're going to do
a guy not that Logan Paul's a fulltime
boxer but at least he focus on it more
than Dylan does so it's like you know
yeah it was it's a bad product as far as
if you're a true fight fan it's a bad
product but I think the takeaway is it's
it's the hype the hype and the buildup
real legit Fighters can take away from
what they're doing not the Dylan danis
girlfriend stuff fiance stuff but as far
as the attraction cuz that got more
Impressions on social media than any
Tyson Fury fight ever Anthony Joshua
Canelo Izzy Jon Jones Brock Lesnar like
they got more impression more eyeballs
than any combat I think it really I
think it really took an emotional toll
on on Logan Paul from what I could feel
I don't know I don't that that could
just be a thing could just thing but I
think I I think I'll tell you why that
guy been through a lot this is this is
his this is his his girl his fiance he
wants to have a family with and the
guy's calling her a [__] you know on a
microphone and I think what happens in
that case is first of all that that's
awful it also hurts your feelings it's
also bad I just hate I hate that [__]
just for the record I [__] hate it I
don't think anybody does I just think
it's it just goes Way Beyond The Pale
that you're attacking his fiance who has
nothing to do with you dude I just think
it's really bad that and and but also I
think for Logan like can you imagine if
he had lost and then he's got to deal
with that so that that puts added
pressure I'm not saying but here here's
here's my here's one of my issues with
these fights yeah every fight notice
every fight Logan take Jake's a little
different but when it talks to KSI when
it comes to Logan Paul name somebody
they fought that could have knocked them
out or that it was it was dicey whether
or not these huge
favorites name one fight where it's a
big risk where they get knocked out well
I think Tommy Fury was a legit boxer I
mean or in terms of you're talking about
Jake Paul I just said take out Jake Paul
let's stick to what we're talking about
got it Logan Paul yeah KSI name one
fight they took where they had the
potential get knocked out go ahead mhm
which one the Floyd Mayweather sparring
match were the guys 140 lbs no can't
knock you out KSI versus Logan ball no
so these fights are all safe cuz these
guys have to protect their online
presence where they don't want to become
a meme so they're fighting and it's a
safe fight for everybody involved and
that's why they're not
exciting Tommy Fury is8 no he's not some
knock he doesn't knock anybody out right
it's a safe fight right right there're
safe fights they don't want to become a
meme so for Dylan danis he's like I just
don't want to become a meme I might lose
but I've already done I'm getting paid
everybody knows my name I got more
followers you ain't making a meme out of
me so that's all they care about the end
of the day the people these young fans
that tune into this they don't know
fighting right they like the buildup
they like all the Antics and all that
they don't care about the actual product
now as real fight fan someone that has
an eye for it you're like what is this
dude right that's the difference yeah
that's kind of how you feel yeah um I
stopped watch KSI Tommy Fury I turned
off after the third round went I'm not
going to was like this is this is stupid
yeah but good there's a lane for it more
power to him yeah but the the my I'm
always interested in
um there is a lane for it but it doesn't
mean it's necessarily that inspired and
it doesn't mean that dise for I no I
disagree I think it's inspiring yeah CU
if so you have a young son when we say
you can do anything you want to do this
proves you can legit do anything you
want to do it you don't have to come
from the slums of Bronxville New York
and become a fighter you don't have to
you can come from calabas you come from
Malibu you can grow up not boxing you
grow up not fighting and get more
eyeballs fighting than anybody any real
professional fighter in the world you do
anything you want to do so for those
young kids that's
inspiring I don't think that getting
eyeballs is a um getting the most
eyeballs is a value system that I would
promote in terms of because you can get
eyeballs doing crazy [__] that
compromises who you are your character
and really even our culture and I think
that vulgarity if if to use a word that
that is to sound like an old guy
vulgarity has been promoted to an art
form I don't think are you referring to
Dylan danis yeah I'm talking about Logan
Paul has I'm talking about spectacle
spectacle versus actual sport uh
entertainment versus you know actual
exploitation I'm just talking in general
I'm not I'm not so much talking you know
maybe that's what I'm talking about
maybe I'm just uneasy with that where
the where the value system for us as a
culture is how many eyeballs can I get
on me and I don't think that's a good
idea yeah there's money that way but I I
think at the end there's all the money
in that but but to your point I think
we're going down a dangerous road again
I support the Misfits and what they're
doing there's a lane for it my issue is
when it gets more views than a Canelo
Charlo fight uh uh usyk Fury fight yeah
that's a problem because this young
audience is watching that going I guess
this is fighting
no no no usyk Fury's legit fight these
guys dedicate their entire lives to the
sport and they've gone through so much
[__] to get here what they're doing yes
it is a form of fighting but it's not
the same yeah so that that's where it
gets and as long as you hold that and
you understand that that it's not the
same and that there is a difference
between sport on a very high level and
what it takes in a lifetime of
dedication and stuff doesn't mean that
Lo Logan Paul and Dylan danis aren't
disciplined in their own way and aren't
athletic in their own way and didn't do
some [__] like I've I've said repeatedly
I do respect what Jake Paul's done it's
really hard to do what he's done like he
puts himself out there he spars all the
time to get that that's very difficult
it's very uncomfortable you take brain
damage you take shots the same with
Logan Paul but we're saying that because
they have money already now what they're
doing is no different than the kid who's
40 in Cuba who's sleeping on the dirt
and getting no money they don't to do
this but they no and that's why it's
that's why it's like okay cud is them
but don't get twisted they're not
Reinventing the wheel there's people
that make $7 a day sparring more than
they are more disciplined than they are
they decid to have they have this
massive fan base decide to go into
boxing but they are playing it safe so
you got to be careful with that there's
a lane for it but yeah something about
it doesn't sit right with me I don't
know what it is that's what I mean like
you well yeah and I think maybe part of
it is they know and you know and
everyone knows I I don't think they
would disagree with this that there is
something about when you when you put
all your attention into eyeballs so it
was like the Paris Hilton phenomenon
Paris Hilton was this this and to an
extent the Kardashians there was this
new Phenomenon with social media where
the number of lenses on you was all you
needed and it didn't almost matter what
it took to be that so all press is good
press right you know and that started
with even Harry Houdini said I don't
care what you write about me just spell
my name right you know so you understand
that to a degree you've always
understood that you know anybody who's
media Savvy understands that but there
is there there should be a standard and
a criteria in many ways just for all of
us as a culture and as a people to
understand that you can make a lot of
money and you can do certain things to
get all the eyeballs on you and you can
throw a lot of other people under the
bus and be cruel and vulgar and all
those things to do that yeah just know
that that is isn't a value system that
is not the ultimate value system there
is something about that that you are
compromising your own soul and your own
self for that I think that's what we all
know inherently maybe that's the I don't
think I think Logan and Dyan are doing
that saying in life I'm saying in
general I think but I think I think we
got to make sure we separate that b
because because what Logan them is doing
it's good in in their Lane I know but I
have to say all due respect to Dylan
danis all due respect I don't approve
and I don't like he's calling Logan
Paul's fiance a [__] I don't like that
I don't think I just think it it demeans
Dylan and and he doesn't need to do that
I don't understand it to have all those
images on his phone and to be putting
them out there I that's just where I
I but remember Dylan didn't start this
Misfit League Dylan is a participant
Logan and Jake and them they're very
good at it so you can't live by the
sword die by can't lump them in with
Dylan Dylan's a one-off in this mhm this
continues without Dylan what Logan Jake
built in this Lane is what's impressive
there's a oneoff so you can't lump him
YouTube movement where these like this
kid comes out to women and goes do you
want to die to see the reaction this
other guy who got shot because he would
come in and like start harassing people
and scaring them and he's a big guy
there's this weird there's this weird
trolling thing that people do on YouTube
these kids that are making a lot of
money that that's how that kid got shot
you know he there's no longevity in it
though cuz at the end day there's no
it's just like this shock yes yes yes
yeah yeah and that that that's I think
we agree I think that's what we're
saying yeah I'm not I'm not lumping
Logan and Jake into that or KSI or Tommy
that Dylan was that oneoff there so you
got to be careful you don't say Well
they're all doing this no no no they
built that Misfits platform and it's
that's their Lane and it's good and they
can do that but you should know what
you're dealing with like when Logan one
called out you know uh what's the
[__] Ry Mysterio Rey Mysterio the WWE
guy like there you go there you go
that's not real yeah and I think I think
overall I Logan Logan's a good example
of a of somebody who follows their
dreams he's disciplined he looks
unbelievable he puts himself in all
these he's an amazing
WWE uh wrestler I mean just so
entertaining and he has grown like that
kid started out as that YouTube
phenomenon he's just steps any Lane that
kid steps into he's he's proof you and
do anything you want yeah not the
biggest guy in the world not the fastest
not the you know you can do anything you
want special yeah Special
it was
interesting yeah well we got uh chamaya
Usman coming up we doing the fight caign
Mr Joe Rogan on uh hamzat Newman yeah I
mean if if you had to right now put I'm
gonna you're going to put uh your money
on your smart money down where do you go
let's look at this you're not you're not
bet on anybody who's taking a fight on
10day notice you're not right no you're
taking Hamot you're taking uh
makev well let's go let's let's go uh
yeah uh I mean Kamar Usman moving up in
weight and if you look at the guys that
move up in weight especially fighting at
a top level they're like two and 40 like
the odds are completely yeah it's awful
I didn't know that mhm
so who's been at 170 versus homite it's
a tough fight at middleweight even
tougher on a 10 days notice bad knees he
can be forced to strike he doesn't
kick stri because his wrestling is no
good here they're going to he might
wrestle but also his knees are
so if he had issues with Leon Edwards
take him down be tough take down hom
that so your for forc a strike you know
he's not the most technical striker in
the world it's gotten better but um you
know he doesn't use his kicks or
anything like that he could get dicey
for him on the feet and then with uh
makev and
volkanovski if this fight was 12 weeks
and vonavi had a chance to prepare
prepare for it I'm putting my money on
vonavi I think he beat him the first
time really yeah but on 10day notice and
and Alexander vov biggest superpowers is
his cardio and he's always training so
let's say his cardio is at a nine yeah
but when his cardio is at a 10 he's
still I would say superpower is his
ability to not take damage at all like
when you saw that that that video of him
there's a video going around after the
fight him walking and he doesn't have a
mark on his face and he's so pissed he
lost it and he just is but remember Mark
CH is not a striker so where would he
take the damage a gra yeah yeah I
understand but he's in general doesn't
take doesn't take damage and so um you
know this will be interesting but you're
you're going you're going my I'm very
curious about this fight because I want
to see if what makach does differently
because the first time he fought him
whatever he was doing did not work to
beat him so what did he yes but what did
he do in his Camp what what different
measures did he take to do what are we
going to see different I think he's
going to Grapple more you do yeah yeah
plus he's had 12 weeks of prepar for you
know Charles so you don't think he'll
strike you think he's going to he's
going to go no you think Islam's going
to be like you know I'm a striker now
but he can strike he's he's a striker
he's still a striker you know yeah not
really he's he's pure grapp I mean
grappling his same as kabib he's better
Striker than kabib but you would not
label him as a striker no I I I think
he's gonna no one VOC taking on T 10day
notice it's be a lot of takedowns
wearing his ass out get him down wear
him out cuz cuz his cardio may not be
what it was but still volcanos is a
professional so even his cardio is still
better than 99% lightweight division but
that's his superpower so it's he's not
the outlier anymore so if his if he went
to a decision which he lost and his
cardio was a 10 you give him 10 days
notice that cardio is a nine I'm leaning
towards Islam man yeah if you take away
his biggest asset in all sports his
cardio you even bring it down a notch
still better than 99% it's not better
than
makev now I'm now who do I want to win
VOS all day he's one of my favorite
Fighters if this was a 12we camp I'm
taking Volcan taking 10 days
tough um I I think this light
heavyweight fight is very interesting to
me and joh yeah yeah unle la is a
monster and uh who I'm I'm going with
magamed on that one I think everybody is
yeah you just got Johnny Walker pull off
like a flying knee or something like
that yeah but Johnny's been winning
fights he shouldn't be winning so we'll
see it's a good great fight but the
winner of Kamar Usman hamai gets the
next middleweight oh ikram alisov is
fighting that's a really good fight
though against warley Alves yeah
ultimate no that's a good fight don't
clown them yeah that's a great fight
sure but then said nurov is a monster
the main card stacked M yeah names are
tough to pronounce but main card stacked
never mind come off yeah s's a monster
he's one of my
favorites yeah we're doing the fight
Comm Mr Joe Rogan
in Austin Texas we'll probably have to
leave on Friday maybe how early card it
is huh I think it starts at 11: or 12
and they're two hours ahead yeah we have
to come in on Friday night
okay it's news to me I think new
hilarious known this forever I know what
it is I had a date funny when the last
time we did companion two months ago I
had a date in Boise and I had to cancel
it so that's that's what it is okay it
says ran wants us there by noon so you
can't they're two hours ahead so you'd
have to let oh we early yeah yeah we
gotta leave Friday night
yeah good thing is you could leave
Saturday
night Friday you could leave Saturday
night back to LA Saturday morning mean
oh yeah yeah we come I will hey I will
yeah all right Chim what do you got for
us because we got Adrian Pearson coming
in we don't want to go too long all
right
cool let's start with uh
sonaz current events here which one we
going with oh okay I don't know what's
going on lately with kangaroos but they
are just picking fights so this guy
who's apparently also an MMA and
jiu-jitsu instructor saw his dog getting
taken by this kangaroo and decided not
today wow the kangaroo just grabs his
dog yeah just grabbed his dog took him
into like a pond or whatever really
let's
see well that's really
strange hey when you guys going to
figure out kangaroo suck oh damn they
attack the guy oh yeah oh yeah taxs the
guy guy drops the
phone play from the beginning chin yeah
damn very Nate Diaz he's off yeah that's
very Nate
Diaz do
buddy go to
my just grabbed his dog and did the guy
get messed up too that water looks real
crocodile punched he did get punched
water looks very crocodile like
seriously get the [__] out of there that
that that's Australia dude I'm already
nervous but why is the kangar just
chilling in the water like this it's
weird yeah taking a
bath and they're laughing too yeah but
that that's does that not look like Croc
that's Australian a nutshell They're
laughing that's what Brandon would look
like if he was a kangaroo just just I'm
pretty muscular too so now you look like
a pray Manas right what else you got um
so this sucks I when we going to figure
out kangaroo suck dude what kangaroos
are [__] figure it out by the way
when we went to Australia they were
because they were SED they were on night
I know they were sedated they're so nice
and they're so calm remember I laid down
next to when P him and I was like is he
just chilling the sun they're like
something like that they like sedated
him so he's just like they they're
they're being fed the entire time so
they're so full yeah yeah but they were
cool with us this sucks yeah uh we
talked about Suzanne simers recently
right yeah she had B used to like I used
to jack off to her Thigh Master videos
as a young man so she died at 76 which
is like that's still young young yeah it
is young but that's after a cancer
battle 23y year battle with a an
aggressive dud she's the original dime
like dude when she was young she was so
pretty yeah she's her man got a face
like me down there what about your dad
looks like your dad looks like me still
stunning 30 years still a babe yeah what
was was tough man nobody gets out of
this
alive all right so here's sir [__] dear
diary don't say stupid things dear diary
bring her up over there her body was St
go back right go back there no no Finn
chin go down go down no it's black and
white keep going down with the big tits
right by the way guys you you have
pointers right you guys you guys have
pointers on right here oh here my
[__] stupid right there bring that
one up no [__] that one right there is
that her right look at her so that's for
Brian and this is for not so much there
more here but you know not my type not
your type right here this looks good oh
no no Brian this is your type she's
going have a giant cck yeah right
imagine me a straight man going nah not
my typ well Bubba I think she didn't
have much of a behind and that I need a
a booty but back in those days boobies
or tits were like very pretty she had a
great personality it was more she was
like just like she was just had
something to her she was funny those
Thigh Master videos just did it for me
that's her older she looks still why is
she sitting like I don't know see I like
that why she sting like that that's
that's fantastic that's a Fant my my my
mom would say don't that's not very
llike and I would say that's okay what
kind of cancer did she have rare form of
an aggressive form of breast cancer you
know what BR does it matter yeah like I
know cancers oh yeah that'll get you I
don't know just move on Chen that
sucks um wait I like this thing
though I haven't actually seen this one
I don't want to do this one oh I watched
us all this week yeah so go for it so
Pete Davidson uh came back SNL is back
this week the writer strike is over and
you know he starts the show by saying we
know what's going on in Israel I'm all
aware of terrorist attacks my dad died
in night 11 and I'm going to do what I
know best and that's to make it
funny I'll be honest with you the show
wasn't that great well Sarah life hasn't
been good in years
so I don't think it's on Pete Davidson
but are people mad that he had that take
on it or no I think people like this no
you got to make I mean they take your
humor away if they take our humor away
then they nothing well no no one's
taking any humor away I'm just saying
did people like this it was received
pretty well it should be yeah his dad
died in 911 for God s right yeah yeah I
like Pete Davon he even alluded to how
they call him butthole eyeses and stuff
like that I love that he plays into that
me too butthole eyes he's like sickly
hot you know like he might be sick but
we don't know yeah he always has
something wrong with him yeah
yeah yeah girls like
him oh my God I mean there's a bunch of
this you can like I feel like I'm just
taking all the mic today okay so Jada
pinket Smith she's got a memoir coming
out in which she's now revealing her and
will have been separated for S years and
she was quote shocked that will referred
to her as his wife after the whole Oscar
slap
thing I I just I can't can't with her
man are kid hey is she when you talk
about eyeballs and like just doing
things for views there you go she is the
worst she is the worst she's a thirst
trap like she's the she's what everyone
warned you about when you're coming up
in the business like dude be careful you
just choose to sleep with because it can
come back and bite you she is the
prototypical worst person well she's
just she'll anything for
attention
what's that got to feel bad for will
will post a video of him laying down
sleeping being like turn him phone off I
mean she also came out and said that you
know she dated Tupac Shakur she actually
said Tupac was her soulmate and is her
soulmate she also came out to sell her
books and she used to sell crack oh God
and no one's buying it like you don't
have to lie to full of [__] in general
like she's a bad person man but also she
and Will Smith had been separated for
seven years that's what she's
claiming but but they were at the Oscars
together yeah so she puts up appearances
is that what it is do they live together
in the same house yes I see and they're
on that show the red table talk all that
[__] but they've been separated
interesting but the but here's where I
think it's good this going to work out
for will all the Hate's going towards
her and people are like oh now I get
will yeah oh no [__] he had to deal with
this all his
life what can your no I'm I got Will's
defense just bleep it out chin yeah we
will yeah but he has to deal with this
like no wonder he's slap people yeah
this poor guy man she's uh you know kids
are all weird gez wonder why well she's
just such a narciss your mom won't pipe
down about sucking off Tupac every
Monday she's just a narcissist she's
such a narcissist you can just see it
everything about her but imagine if your
girl every she imagine she had a
following and just kept talking about
her act all the time like hey [__] can
you not do that all the time can you
show me a little respect well my would
be also um you you kind of pick up on a
narcissist after a while you're like man
you are all about yourself you just go
with the wind don't you like how much
attention do you need and I'm sorry but
her husband is so much more famous so
much more talented he's so much more
talented he's so much more charismatic
was aad and she can't stand it she
can't Jada pink and Smith saying he was
in the reason we talk about Jada pink
and Smith is because because of Will
Smith you're welcome for Will Smith now
I have to say personally the only reason
we know about her is because of willth
yes but I will say that physically I
find her impossibly attractive like just
physically I think she's very hot I
think what she's doing makes her not
like I used what she's doing no now I
look at her as like evil I go I don't
but I mean hey Rich Do You Realize Will
Smith was in sharktail he's he's
he's a giant in Hollywood Giant and
she's yeah what's the last thing she was
in though what's the last thing she was
in menace to society was was the one
thing she did she was great M soci
that's a great but what's the last big
thing she's done she's um let's see
besides R off Will's coattails should I
say
sharktails like that I love that movie
he's got a lot of Banger movies oh Will
Smith top top 10 suit of Happ he's as
big a movan of all his movies but yeah
sure as big a movie star as you
get Queen
Cleopatra what's the big movie shoes in
not a lot the previous let's look not a
lot just good at staying good at real
good at staying um relevant in any way
she
can red table talk okay that's her show
Annie yeah
okay Secret Life of Bees oh she was in
Karate Kid well cuz her son was in it
and will direct it what what else she
what else she in that The Equalizer
nothing nothing nearly in the area code
that Will Smith no Will Smith is M The
Matrix
that's Matrix
yeah is she is she getting those calls
to be in all these movies if she's not
married to right Men in Black Will
Smith oh she was a party guest yeah but
I'm saying so she definitely got she
done much though so the coil thing is
checking out yeah she stayed
relevant she stayed relevant by knowing
who to be married to make no mistake it
seems to me she now she throw under the
bus she's all about herself now she
throw under the bus that's what that's
what drives me nuts and she's trying to
act like she had this tough upbringing
selling cracks like who are you lying to
did she say did she say he was gay is
that what what she was saying no no no
no so people were asking if it was true
if the rumors were true that he was gay
or they're both gay and they have an
open relationship she said all that's
false but yeah I'm not buying any of it
but I think this is good for Will Smith
I think most people are like I feel bad
for will man lady sucks slowly comes
back to Hollywood insert will kick her
out of the club well look and look what
happened right like you said like he's a
legend the Oscar things happens he's
banned from the Oscars for 10 years and
he did that for her and now she throws
him under the bus yeah and now we all
feel bad for him she's like we together
and Will's like what I didn't know that
that was such a dumbass move though that
the slap was so lame so fake it was like
well that slap
was my my opinion of that is what
happens when you get really famous is
you can't help but to say I think I'm
one of God's favorites and then if
you're not careful if you're not careful
you you might say I might be I might be
God himself I might be gay I can do
things that no one else can ever real
serious true but that's true so that
that arrogance that hubris when and and
apparently I heard his career went
downhill once he bought a Tesla well no
no apparently our boy Denzel Washington
said that great line he said the Devil
comes for you in your high moment and I
went like this I read that on Hallmark
car Mr Washington well it's it's true
though yeah but that wasn't I guess he
won the Oscar that's a high moment and
he won an Oscar yeah yeah do you think
she like whispered in his ear in that
moment and was like you better [__]
do something I don't think so you they
the word is she looked at him like
really and he was like oh [__] I better
do something maybe I'll win her back I
didn't see that though did she said she
didn't see the slap is that what I just
saw she said that yeah which is so
stupid everyone saw that Len she was
sitting in the front row what are you
talking
about and that's the same article where
she said she doesn't she says all the
rumors about them being gay open
relationship is false so who knows
clearly clearly she's full of [__] yes
poor Will Smith yeah dude I think good
for will though and we care about will
here so we want will to come back MH
well but set it off that was a good that
was a good movie that that was in 199
too but I'm that was a good movie
Professor another good one that one too
that was Eddie Murphy yep she was killed
in Scream too she
was stuff she's done some stuff not
recently but yeah yeah back in the day
though she was oh The
Inkwell okay move on she'll do whatever
she asked you to stay men Society I
already said 21 Jump Street greatest
show of all time doie
Hower she's a lot of stuff no we're keep
going all right what else you um all
right let's see wait with another one
from son right I don't think so okay
never mind
huh oh well kind of which one
um the I lost it oh the Jimmy Allen won
oh the Jimmy Allen or it let me look for
it Jimmy Allen oh the black guy the
singer country s the country singer so I
got a question for you be when you go to
your kids baseball games do you carry a
knife cuz Jimmy Allen does that means he
can't fight he's at his kids football
game wielding a knife and like openly
exposing it to everyone who's there well
it's like on his Hip Pocket yeah can we
pull up the pictures he got in trouble
recently right with his assistant or
something like that he was like trying
to force her to Su his Wier what the who
is this WOW nobody knows this stuff huh
I don't know who Jimmy Allen Jimmy
Allen's a big country music artist he
was on American Idol recently as a as
like a guest uh performer on there but
he
that's how I mean it looks pretty big
but yeah he might be going through some
stuff cuz I I know he got a divorce from
his wife they have like three little
kids so he might be going through some
stuff I definitely don't show up uh to
any games with a large knife sheath
knife yeah that's interesting he's got a
lot going on right now I know he's
counter suing as like former manager
yeah he's a lot of issues allegations
and stuff going on but I mean maybe he's
getting like like threats so maybe he
feels like he has to carry a knife I
doubt it's for the other dads on the
team yeah every said that he had a
really Pleasant attitude and great
conversations at the game though so it's
weird he's like K can you drop the
machete though next time well he's like
I brought to slice the oranges at
halftime like that makes sense yeah
huh he's just going through some hard
time he's counter suing a woman for
alleging he had sexual assault yeah had
some issues with that stuff I don't know
what else you got Jen well I mean this
is kind of like bad timing but Colin
[__] Noir posted this he tagged you and
it with his uh
TRX this truck is a
murderer oh look at that right there in
the
a yeah thing is a Sero
[Music]
killer now if they're a piece of deer on
it or something I'd be like all yeah
because it's such a massive truck like
when I was driving to Sacramento I think
just the path we took there was
mosquitoes everywhere probably killed
10,000 mosquitoes
just you know just when you're
driving that's the Lord's work right
there oh mosquitoes are [__] worse
dude they're popping right now too man
my ankle's all tore yeah my kid I don't
get bit my kid gets bit my some people
don't get bit he's got pock marks every
like boom boom boom boom boom they love
them they don't bite me yeah so people
have certain like things I guess your
sweat or whatever Jay doesn't get bit
either but I get bit so much I literally
don't get bit my mother would come in
wake me up and they would swarm on her
they just she get bit by 50 m there
something they don't dig yeah I don't
know smell or something yeah I don't
know what it is it's my it's my holy
ghost
power what uh this is an old one I just
thought this was funny so I'll like play
it real quick if
it hold
on computer's getting a little slow
right now
Chuck Norris makinging Chuck Norris
jokes this is awesome hey someone says
Chuck Norris is dropped twice when he
has a baby once in Hiroshima and once a
Nagasaki holy
[__] when Chuck Norris turned 18 his
parents moved
out Chuck North learned to read from a
book he
wrote all right it's not working give me
a sec here it's just him read here it is
hold on and bent down I petted him he's
talking about tiger all sudden he heard
this like that so the trainer says get
up very slowly and back up so the tiger
did he slowly got
up so the tiger did that's fun good
that's good all right um is there
anything else I think it's time bringing
Adrian Peters all right cool bringing
Adrien Peterson I think the man the
legend the myth is here it is Adrian
Peterson Hall of Fame running back one
of the greatest ever do it beat me 50
to3 okay yeah but he is live in studio
and he's on Dancing With the Stars yeah
built like scoring touchdowns and
winning your hearts on Dancing With the
Stars yep it's Adrien Peterson symmetry
the Symmetry meter is about to hit 1,000
Adrien Peterson what a special episode
Brian what a special episode 14 years in
the NFL which is unheard of it's ridic
ridiculous to be a running back and now
a dancer did a little pouette for me and
you're built his technique was good he's
built like a dancer I said it I said
he's built like a football player why I
cuz I I I've been around some dancers
they don't look like that listen man
admit it you're you're 212 lbs you
played at 220 you're in dancer shape
what how how is how is it going I
because a an athlete of your caliber can
tell his body to do anything it wants
yeah how how are you doing as a Dan just
so the fans know CU Adrian's on Dancing
With the Stars so and most of the time
guys that had I mean Legends like a like
himself when they go on Dancing With the
Stars do very well cuz the footwork yes
so go ahead yeah I feel like I'm doing
doing well it was rough starting off um
you know I hadn't really been active
like that so a lot of muscles started
you know started to kind of fire in in
different places I'm like man is it
harder than you expect it it is it
Wasing right everyone says it like the
commitment like the practices like you
guys cuz you got
toop like 4 and a half hours a day like
it was it was brutal you know like just
mentally you know cuz you have to be
engaged and locked in and listening to
the music right yeah listening to the
music and being um in tune you know you
got to be in tune with the music and
it's like no really no room for error
because once the music start playing if
you take the wrong step wrong move it
throws off the routine you know a lot of
pressure a lot of pressure that comes
with it yeah yeah and when when how'd
this come about when dance Stars called
you were like yeah I'll do it you can't
be that tough so the funny thing is they
um the first time they came around I was
with the Vikings and um I really was
like you know what uh I don't really
want to do it you know I was kind of
nervous to kind of put myself out there
like that and then I was playing
football so I kind of had a little
excuse right so um this time when it
came around you know I've been out for
two years I'm just like man you know
this is something that can be
challenging for me and um you know I can
kind of get outside of you know my
element and try something different you
know and so I I I accepted to do it so
you're enjoying it yeah I me how's been
the transition playing that intensely
for 14 years now what's it like to not
play at all like all of a sudden you
don't have a regimen you don't have that
strict schedule and now it's like see
you later go do your thing asse it's
tough for him cuz you're talking about
one of the greatest to ever do it so
it's not like you're just this guy who
played like four or five years and it's
like ah getting the real estate you're
talking about a guy like that's that's
that's your thing Heisman Trophy winner
rush for 2,000 yards like one of the
greatest to ever do it and then it's
just over yeah yeah it was rough they
robbed me for the Heisman yeah agree but
I I you know I in my mind I want it yeah
so I give it to you you know Matt ler
you can have it at your spot but I I
think they robbed you cuz they gave it
to your boy Jason White before right so
they didn't want two Oklahoma boys to
win it yeah now I just real quick for
answer well I played against Adrian I
played for University of Colorado in the
Big 12 Championship oh you did and we
knew he was good like I you know you
hear about him right and I remember in
warm-ups and I was like where's Adrian
and I was like oh my God and then when
he got the ball I was like oh we're
screwed we lost 50 to three a different
we lost 50 to to what we lost 50 to 3
and he was just running yeah so a good
pet well he runs high like that's his
style and I was like oh what are we
going to do we l 50 to3 and it could
have been 100 to three but they were
cool you sat out my buddy had to cover
um Randy Moss once and he goes oh that's
why I'm never going to play in the NFL
and he was a D1 he played a Ball State
but he went oh this is a whole different
thing yeah you
know and why did you what like the crazy
thing is to play 14 years as a running
back is I don't think I don't know of
any running back who played that long
maybe if you go back to the 70s or the
80s but for the most part you know
nowadays especially you you play for
five years that's a long that's a long
time yeah and 14 years and with the NFL
obviously I mean the the injury rate's
100% how did you do it what is there do
you think you have a a sort of a I have
this philosophy or this this Theory I
have a theory that guys like pton
Manning Brady they have the ability at
the last second Drew bre to just they
when they see the hit they can kind of
they do I don't know there's something
but he can't do that those are white
quarterbacks what a stupid why make a
race there because he's a [__] giant
black running back who gets hit every
single it's not giant but but for
running back he's a giant well no he's
it's ridiculous that you were able to
take that kind of pounding mhm what what
is it um God yeah genetics literally
genetics genetics had a lot to do with
it um but it's a mindset too yeah you
know um for me I I always had the
mindset that I wanted to be the hammer
you know so that's why I play so
aggressive and it's I tell people all
the time it's funny because the same
thing that you SE me do in college and
in NFL I did it in Little League I did
it in middle school I did it in in high
school you know but it was that same
mentality be a hammer beat the hammer
because you know as a running back when
you get the ball you got guys
everybody's coming to attack you so you
have to accept the president say hey
when guys are watching
film H you know you got to make them
question if they want to come low or if
they want to you know make a business
decision you have to you got to you got
to make those guys think that type of
way so I think for me that was
beneficial because guys knew when they
play against me like d you know this guy
even when he gets hit and get caught
from time to time whenever happened he's
coming back to the next play and he's
coming even harder yeah it hurts you
know so you you delivering the
punishment instead of a lot of running
backs accept it or try to Juke out of
the way and get hit but I think it's
interesting too and I I don't know if
there's going to be a running back who's
going to be able to get to your level as
far as the the rushing yards the how
many how long you played because now the
running back position it's just changed
yeah like you look at even like saquon
Barkley who they had to you know they to
give franchise him or you look at uh
Taylor at Indie who that out now the NFL
is kind of going away from the running
back these guys aren't getting valued
like they when you were playing it was a
big deal what do you mean by this I'm
sorry I'm a little ignorant the the
running back because so like saquon
Barkley who some people think he's the
best running back in the league he want
a long-term deal and guaranteed money
the owners are going you're a running
back they get hurt you know they get
hurt all the time or the NFL is it's a
pass League now so they're they you have
to be a guy like chrisan mcaffrey or
Kamar you know that with the New Orleans
who can do it all they have to be able
to catch and so as far as like the just
the running back with a fullback they're
going away from those days so I I think
you're like the Last of a Dying Breed
yeah it's it's unfortunate you know how
guys are they're running back you know
um or they're being treated is it's
ridiculous you know um but you know I
think guys like christien guys like
Barkley you know Alvin Kamari um you
know Derrik Henry you know I think he's
like that right now kind of that last
true like North and South Pound guy
Henry for sure Henry's a guy who played
similar to you yeah um I think they'll
keep it alive um you know the thing that
bothers me the most is like you see the
situations running backs are in and how
they're being treated as soon as playoff
time come that's who you rely on you
rely on the running back you know so I
feel like once guys get to the point
where they're they're willing to
sacrifice you know what I'll sit out you
know I'll sit out year and when and then
when multiple guys do that agree then
you know I think they'll it'll be a new
president you know like people these
organizations start respecting that
position more when they see that you
know what we can't you know every team
don't got a uh a a Debo you know where
you can move a guy from receiver to play
you know play the running back position
to kind of make up when you know a guy
is hurt or you need you know another guy
back there so um
you know I you know um I think a good
group of running backs came out this
year big you know so the guy from
um oh my God so talented I was watching
some highlights the other day cut I said
okay he he he's on he got me on his
radar right now you know I'm like I'm
I'm going to watch this kid play cuz he
that's aing a lot cuz he's a Texas kid
yeah you know and I really didn't get to
watch him you know I heard a lot about
him being in Texas didn't really get to
watch him that much but in college but
my uncle who lives down there in Austin
who played for Texas you know he was
telling me about him too so I end up
catching a game and I'm just like okay
this kid right here you talking about he
plays physical you know he's quick that
jump cut is ridiculous you know got
really good hands like good allaround
back so um I feel like you know guys
like that will make the owners put some
respect how good he was and then even
it's like with the teams like he was
drafted what like running backs now like
no one's going in the top 10 like I
think he went what 15 to 20 something
Passing League passing but then also
they get injured a lot and then they're
not getting paid like let's say my son
was gifted at football which he is the
running backs aren't getting the same
money as a receiver or a tackle or
quarterback or DB or a linebacker like a
rush end they're just not getting the
same money cuz the NFL the owners
they're wrong they go we can just put
anybody in there and get yards yeah and
they're so wrong with your speed and and
your intelligence did anybody try to
make you a quarterback make you a uh a
wide receiver I mean because I feel like
you could have played those Ro those
positions easily and been just as yeah
as effective yeah no I never got that
opportunity I tried in high school and
my high school coach was like uh no sir
you're too strong yeah I'm like coach I
can play defense
too yeah I can play defense and be
productive on the defense side of the
ball he was like Adrian I know you can I
know you could do it but we going going
to keep you for the running back
position you know so a could have played
both I I honestly think you could have
played defense as well there's two plays
in particular I remember uh one was
against the Steelers and you rushed for
a touchdown but you literally just threw
your shoulder into the guy and knocked
him flat out like a linebacker you know
I mean you could do both so I I'm
surprised you weren't pushed to do
actually and I think the closest to him
right now would be a Christian mcaffrey
and not sizewise but I mean you guys
play similar Christian runs the hardest
I've seen NL
now's retired right I know but I'm
saying Mar was was a well if you want to
go back guys retired Jim Brown Jim Brown
make guys pay Jim Brown make guys super
pay but currently guys like Chris
mcaffry no one runs harder than mcaffrey
and Debo them boys when they get the
ball you're like look out man yeah they
run really really hard the guy down in
um in Vegas runs really hard to Jacob oh
yeah Jacob's talented another guy was
wanting to get paid was leading rusher
in the NFL and they're just not paying
them yeah you know it sucks because it
doesn't suck because it's really good
that you get so many talented guys that
come out that might not have you know
the success in college that you would
think you know like Reggie Bush or you
know Marshal Lynch or something like
that um and they kind of FL go on the
radar or whatnot and then they get to
the NFL and get the opportunity and you
know they take their game to a totally
different level see I I think if the
shame on Reggie Bush with his talent
like say he was in the San Francisco
49ers offense or New Orleans he would
have been all pro six years in a row but
back then they weren't using the running
back like they are now like Reggie could
catch he he go into slot he could do all
that but they didn't they weren't set up
for that so he is forced to run on third
down he's not a third down back he's too
small so he didn't have a he had a
decent career but man if he was like in
his prime today with what the way they
can maneuver him in a Shanahan offense
Superstar yeah but at the day he was
just a guy like you had to run between
the tackles and it was during your days
too so it's like that ain't happening he
had to run between the tackles a little
more but he got lucky cuz he was one of
the few guys that was that ended up in
New Orleans you know with Shan Peyton
and Shan pton you know like that's the
style that he's always looking for you
know the Alvin Kamari type guy you know
um so he got kind of Lucky being you
know selected to go there you know and
be be a part of that offense um I think
when he took that hit you know the
famous hit I think that kind of knocks
some of the juice out of like you know
what yeah you know cuz I've always
thought like man if regie had my
mentality or martial L Type mentality
far as like North and
South you get that mentality that do you
think that was inherent or is that from
your upbringing like that's a very you
think it's cuz you're the biggest
eight-year-old on the Block you know so
here's the funny here's the funniest
thing and um I'm experiencing now like
with my son like Adrian Jr like he's
like he's ripped up you know but he's
but he's slam you know like you see him
out there he's smaller than everyone you
know um how old is he he's uh 11 11 I
have a eight 8-year-old too where he's
he's really Slim slim too but really
muscular but he's like when you see him
he stands he's tall I think he's going
to be like 6'3 or whatnot um but like
even when I was younger I was I had the
same frame so I really wasn't like the
biggest kid you know but I had the
biggest heart and I I was just wire
different you know I was tough as Nails
um but that that comes from a upbringing
you know like so you know when when I
was seven I lived in Dallas me and my
mom and my two of my cousins my aunt we
lived in these apartments in Dallas and
I had an older brother who was eight and
he passed away there and we end up
coming back home to Palestine but I
never forget my mom had went to work and
we was standing with my uncle my uncle
was babysitting us and we weren't
supposed to be outside and of course the
coolest Uncle you know yeah you guys go
outside and play so I'm outside playing
football ironically and my brother was
riding a bike with his friends and uh he
end up getting hit by a car oh my God
getting hit by a car what a disaster
what a dis you know like for me at that
age I
remember somebody running over and it
was like AG your you know your brother
got hit so I just remember sprinting
over there to him and I remember his
head was like three times the size of
his normal you know and I remember
getting on my knees and like raising his
head up and like calling his name
calling his name and he didn't respond
laid him back down and I remember
spraying over to my aunt's house and
just banging on the door banging on the
door and I was like a you know Brian
just got hit by a car and she was on I
remember never forget like it was
yesterday she was on the phone she
dropped the phone and she was like you
know come in the house lock the door and
then as I go into the house I see the
ambulance come right so um God God get
to the hospital later that day and you
know he was pronounced brain he was
pronounced brain dead so for me like
going through that and like seeing that
happen and like that entire experience
and then coming back to Palestine you
know you know maybe like a week or two
later have the funeral I didn't cry at
all was all my tears were were gone by
that time right and I remember we moved
in with my grandmother and there was a a
plant room that she had all her plants
in but was it had a bed and then it was
a a door and then this other room was my
uncle's room who he had I think he was
at he wented to University of Texas at
that point but uh that was his room
right and my mom slept there we stayed
there for like a year and every single
night I I would hear my mom in her
crying you know every night every every
night and I should go in there and try
to you know cons hey Mom it's going to
be okay whatever whatever so I grew up
fast and that that right there like end
the end of your
yeah it hardened me right it hardened me
at a young age and for me I always
looked at it CU my brother was way he
was way more talented than me like way
more talented than me such a shame smart
like he was just brilliant and so for me
anything that I did after that point it
was like I'm not only am I'm doing it
for myself but I'm doing it for my
brother too cuz he couldn't you know
what I'm saying so that always allowed
me to like play aggressive and play with
the edge you know take out anger and
frustration um you know that I know came
from you know from dealing with that
situation along with other situations as
well you know what I'm saying and then
of course when you grew up you know with
eight cousins you know boys and you had
uh six six uncles you know what I'm
saying and they all that's just all
testosterone that's just all boys so
people see my dad my dad like 64 230 and
they like wow we see we see where you
get it from right oh yeah but I I tell
them all the time I said that's a fluke
you know like my dad like my dad
genetics obviously as well helped me you
know have the type of you know body
style and the talent and ability that I
have but my mom's side yeah like that's
where the goons are you know I'm saying
oh yeah like my mom was 113 she went to
University she was 113 and 100 I had a
yeah yeah that's where the spe come from
I had I had an uncle his name was a Ally
Brown he played for Pine Bluff he
actually played for Arizona for for
about about three 3 or 4 years but in
high school I broke all his records damn
he was he was 62 230 he was like a 4
five guy he had a 7 foot high jump Jesus
in high school freaks yeah oh my
godak my my oldest Uncle he was po
Sailor Man like before he passed even
when I was in my Prime playing football
for the Minnesota Vikings ripped up
shredded he was always more ripped up
than me you know what I'm saying yes he
played he um he was like a 43 guy like
super strong used to pick up cars like
the backup cars literally pick up cars
and move them it's a family of freaks
man I had my uncle uh Chris Smitt he
went to the University of Texas he
actually played around he played the
time with like Ricky and Apple White and
all those guys studs Sho he was 67 270
lbs Dam just ripped up all on Mom's side
all on my mom's side and then my aunt my
oldest aunt she she was way faster than
my mom but she was too busy beating
people upol you come from X-Men you come
frommen pretty much Professor but but I
also do believe that there are a lot of
really great athletes out there that
don't play for 14 years and a lot of
that is also the idea that you you you
know you I think when you go through
something that that horrendous that
catastrophe it's got to just gge you for
anything man for anything like
discomfort on that level yeah yeah it
was rough man you know you know who
helped navigate it who helped you derive
meaning from it your mother um football
yeah just just just football man and you
know my mother us just being there for
for each other um what not but a lot of
prayer you know um cuz you know I big in
my faith is for us you know God never
give you put more on you that you can
handle you can bear you know what I'm
saying so for me I always kind of found
comfort and you know reading the
scriptures and understanding that like
the you know job and what he went
through and like wow you know like to be
able to end do that you know and
continue to press on and keep fa exactly
um and did your mom know how you know
the Book of Job I don't just the the
devil says to to says to God he says
your faithful servant job I can turn him
I can take everything away from him and
then he'll turn away from you the reason
he loves you is because you've given him
so much and God takes that bet did did
your mom know how special you were at
football like was she always like stick
to football make sure you get the grades
like you can do things with this cuz
because so everyone's so athletic in
your family yeah I'm sure like you
weren't an outlier but did your mom know
that you had the special set of skills
to be one of the top five running backs
of all time yeah she she that's that's
ins she seen the ability you know um a
lot of people don't know like track was
my second my second love so at one point
during my sore year I was just like I
was going to X football out and just in
high school yeah and just focus on track
uh cuz me the coach had you know we kind
of buted heads or whatever um but um she
inspired me to stay Dash huh was it yeah
100 200 um was pretty my pretty much my
events so but uh yeah my mom was she was
died into it she was just like hey
whatever you want to do you know I'm
supporting you so if that's track if
that's football whatever it is I know
you know if you put your mind to it and
keep working like you've been working
then you can you know succeed in either
one and then was the family cool growing
up in Texas that you went to you committ
to Oklahoma how'd that choice come out
now my uncle didn't like it he was you
known alumni yeah he's a longhorn he
actually still lives in Austin um he
didn't like it but you know he
understood my logic behind it you know
at that time was the logic I mean
Oklahoma was big at the time too yeah so
for me I I feel disrespected for one um
because from my my junior year on I was
the number one recruit in the country
you know I had already tooken my SAT and
you know whatever and qualified and all
that and Texas was like the third school
to offer me a scholarship and I'm right
there in your backyard I've been a
number one recruit in the country since
my junior year up the street yeah you
know and then I had God did they Texas
A&M Oklahoma offer me scholarships I you
imine me long hey hey guys like who is
responsible how do we [__] miss that
guy you know what I'm saying rival
somebody got fired yeah so it was so
that rubbed me the wrong way first off
and then you know once I went to go
visit UT like I L it there you know like
I'll never forget like even when my
uncle was there I remember standing
after a spring game they had right and
I'm waiting for him to get dressed and
come out and the Stadium's empty like I
remember looking out at the stadium just
like man I'm going be back here what
they like I was UT all the way you know
what I'm saying and you know when that
recruiting process came about is just
you know once I took a visit to Texas
and then I took a visit to Oklahoma I
was like man this is pretty much the
University of Texas in Oklahoma yeah
there's so many guys from Texas that
that that they pull from Texas that go
to Oklahoma right most of the team right
yeah and then the one thing that stood
out the most to me which is what I
dedicate myself to is you get out what
you put in so that grind was different
you know like is that a Stoops thing
like the culture he created yeah the
culture he he created with the staff
that he brought in there a guy by name
of uh Jerry Smith we call him Smitty and
uh you know the guys in fraternity we
just like you know guys are Smitty Built
right so it was just his regimen and the
way these guys grind compared to what I
seen at Texas cuz I never understood I'm
like CHR univ versus Texas man like we
got I feel like Texas is the best
football you get all the top recruits to
go to University of Texas and then you
you're pulling guys in from different
states as well like why come we not up
there you know why come it's not a
dynasty like Alabama was you know what
I'm saying cuz you got all the talent
yeah so for me during that time it was
like these guys not really putting their
work in they're just relying on Talent
you know what I'm saying and hard work
out does Talent when talent doesn't work
hard and that's what it was say that
again hard hard work does Talent when
talent doesn't work hard and that's what
it was with Oklahoma you know they had
guys that weren't as Talent they had
guys that were talented too but they had
guys that weren't as talented but those
guys grinded you know so when I got to
Oklahoma it was the same thing like it
was that grind and that's what I love
who's who's going to develop me the best
to to get to the ultimate goal you like
the grind you embraced the grind it was
oh yeah that's yeah did that happen did
did you have a coach in high school did
that to you is that what it was you were
just used to it yeah I was just used to
it but that was my mentality too like
for me it was like okay I understood a
young age like I always wanted to play
in NFL it was never College I had
overlooked all that I was like I'm going
to play in NFL one day right but for me
I knew at a young age that I was more
talented than the kids around me you
know I was faster I was Stronger um you
got that right away how old were you
when that happened eight seven eight
okay like I you know and um so I knew
those things right and then I'm seeing
I'm seeing my uncles I'm hearing stories
about them and all this so I knew that I
was getting Cut From a Different Cloth
you know what I'm saying like from a
different breed right this is your
destiny and I always knew I say you know
what not only am I the you know the most
talented but if I work the hardest they
can't keep up they can't keep up it's
it's it can be a blessing and a curse
cuz if you realize you're more talented
than everybody then you're like I can
kind of Coast not work as hard but then
when you get a guy who has all the
talent he's more talented than everybody
but then out Works them they're screwed
there's nothing they can do they're
never going to catch up never scary
that's Oklahoma that's why still into
people and my kids today I'm just like
man you guys are really blessed and
talented but you have to put the work in
yeah man got to put the work in I've
seen guys that had that had the same
amount of talent that I had but didn't
put the work in yeah they they go by the
wayside and they just kind of you watch
other sports are you a fan of uh
anything like UFC or or any um I watch
basketball from time to time I'm a fan
of those like UFC and boxing and stuff
like that too but I'm not going to lie
and say that you I'm sitting there
watching you still watch you watch a lot
of NFL or college yeah like did you
watch I me off your Sooners beat uh the
Longhorns the yeah yeah yeah yeah so I
didn't get to watch it like I wanted to
cuz I was actually rehearsing at doing
rehearsals I'm sorry fellas Miss game I
was
dancing how many dances they have you
doing now so right now we on the the
fourth dance fourth dance the fourth
Dance I'm doing the uh vietamese Walts
the Vietnamese oh the Viet Walts viese
WTS and who and who's your partner her
name her name is Brit Stewart yeah so
everybody's pretty pumped up cuz this
week is uh the hunt uh the
100 anniversary of Disney so um it's
like the hund the Disney all Disney
theme I love when they do that yeah yeah
I do so tomorrow it's turning up it's uh
100 Disney Night Disney night and uh
we'll be dancing to some of your your
favorite Disney movies man and some of
your favorite soundtracks and who who
who else is on the show with you as far
um you got um any other
athletes no other athletes no no NFL
guys always do well Jason morz I'm
saying his name right yeah Jason morz y
he's he's on there um look at that look
at that reach you got that I me I like
the lines I like the lines telling you I
got to have more you know I got to have
those fingers together you got that
right there man the wrist is pointed
perfectly you're natural that's what I
was doing at my rehearsal I was just
like and looking at back at my phone
like okay now you do that same you do
that same kind of wrist movement in the
NFL think there's some sugar in your
tank you want to touchdown
hey it's very anti football changed oh
yeah that's called graceful but you get
along with everyone the the whole staff
the other contestants everything oh yeah
it's all good it's all love man we all
want to see each other perform Well's no
dancer you don't have any injuries right
I mean I feel like you're no I'm good
man that's crazy bro bad KN your knees
are good everything knees are good man
that's nuts I I roll up the bed feel
amazing you know so you know when I was
with Seattle I played that one game and
um I ended up having to ended up with a
pinch nerve yeah it kind of developed
later that in your neck or where was it
at it was like my my lower back nothing
nothing worse right listen when I tell
you that was something that kind of
opened my mind like wow like the body is
crazy you know something as
simple as how it happen it can shut you
shut you down completely it was it
happened on my my second we was on the
goal line the second touch sound attempt
and I never forget I I think the guard
maybe got pushed back and I had to jump
I had to jump over him right and as soon
as I I came down a det tackle was coming
right and and grabbed me and he fell I
fell on my side he landed complet me wow
and I didn't really think too much of it
then and even actually after the game
later on that day I was sitting around I
made a move I was like whoa I feel like
a short pain I was like oh what was that
that didn't feel right you know so
didn't really think too much about it
Monday come around and I remember
getting up raising up out the bed and I
tried to I pull my right leg and I tried
to move my left leg over and it was
stuck like it was like it was paralyzed
she couldn't move it oh [__] and then it
kind of went away and I I stood up and
walked around didn't really think too
much about it and went into a facility I
worked out I did squats I did everything
right and um I told the trainers about
it and it was like okay we going to
watch it and let us know how it feel
come Wednesday we get out there for
walkth through right
and you know Russell he calls outside
outside Zone play and I stepped to the
left for my Landmark stepped to the left
and like for me my walkthrough is is
pretty much like a 3/4 speed you know
what I'm saying so I step to the left
and I feel flat on my face boom like my
leg to shut down whoa yeah yeah so
serious is that like your first bad
injury kind of uh like to that magnitude
did you have to have an operation for
that no no I didn't thank God they they
wanted me to um but I was like exactly I
was like uh I want to just you know ride
it out see how it it heals what would
you traction you just like lay down just
let it heal on its own then yeah that's
that's why it took it took a while
though cuz I kept freak genetic it but
uh kep yeah kept going in to check it
yeah I was
like X-Men [__] that Wolverine [__]
what' you do I just drank some milk and
woke up fine man it it it is a different
it's like yeah just it's just different
anal shout out to technology cuz now
like if guys like back in the day you
two 10 years ago to your ACL you're
you're done especially as run back done
Davis days you're done MCL ACL PCL
you're screwed like Bo Jackson where the
whole hip thing if it was today Bo's
still playing B's year off
has
surgery might be the biggest freak of
all time like you talk to anybody out
there biggest freak of even Deion
Sanders recently interview they said
biggest freak he goes I was a freak and
he goes and we were we were at the same
time FSU and Auburn and he goes and I
heard about Bo Jackson and he was like
I'm G to show him what's up and he
talked about they show the highlight and
Bo Jackson has a sweet play he's coming
out and Dion's like I'm about to light
this fool up he goes to attack him dude
b boom stiff arm he's like God well I
worked with him for a week his fingers
are that fat he's 245 without lifting
weights 61 I think that was a different
bow that's like the bow that eats fast
food no he was a big dude he weighed
exactly he told me because this is this
is 25 years ago he said I weigh exactly
as much as I did and he never lifted
weights never did [__] he would just
strap it on and go that's what he told
me he was just like some fre freaks well
I know I'm be tuning in Dancing with the
Stars now man got to I've always been a
fan from the outside even though you
beat us 50 to3
all right I get it but uh we appreciate
you coming on man it gave you it gave
you a barometer of where you stand
versus where one of the great stands oh
NFL's not for me yeah last question is
there any other running back that you
look at that kind of a you or I mean
people would put you in the top five top
10 of all time what what is there
anybody that you kind of like all time
you're saying or you're saying now all
time all time all time yeah okay so
what's the chrisan who you who who was
there a running back you ever tried to
model yourself on after or are you just
your own thing uh I was just my own
thing but guys that inspired me was like
Walter Peyton watching his film you know
um I was not as elusive as Barry Sanders
but who don't who's not inspired by him
right Barry Sanders um Emma Smith um you
know me being a taller back you know
Eddie George and oh yeah those type of
guys trell Davis like his story and how
he came from special teams and just
grind that hard work right guys like
that really uh you know inspired me but
funny thing is too like you talk about
my style and how I say I've always
played aggressive like aggressive like
that
um think about going up there to the
University of Texas and watching Ricky
run that ball yeah Ricky Williams you
know what I'm saying Ricky Williams
before you you know who you the closest
I've seen and he didn't have the same
NFL career but the closest I've seen to
you recently would be forette for LSU
and they went to Tampa but he he runs
similar yeah he runs hard run I think
any of those guys when I if I asked them
the same question that you'd be in their
list too so I would hope so man I played
the game to uh to leave a stain and you
know memories for people to missish 14
years with good needs and now you're
taking on Dancing we wish you the best
we know you got to roll cuz you got to
you got to this is your life now you got
to rush out of here to do rehearsals
yeah I got to do that but you know I got
want to tell everybody to tune in
tomorrow yes um 8 Eastern 7 central time
you can also vote uh you can uh text
Adrian to
21523 up to 10 times and then you can
also um go online and vote at dancing
withth the stars. ABC do.com and you can
vote up to 10times for the kid fans vote
for him make sure we get get you into
the finals yeah Adrian Peterson Adrian
appreciate coming on man good luck yeah
man that was
great